Je pense qu'ils peuvent avoir la circulation sont dans le
devant mon tam ce menu j'ai trouvé
une invitation
Je n'ai pas commencé à avoir notre cours, j'y vais
Cherche, j'y vais, c'est pour un jour que je me suis levé
ton équipe croustillante qui s'attarde
pour retourner utiliser il m'a pris
international ce gain principal de
une décoration comme celle-ci, elle ne lui donne même pas le style de patte
cette condition doit être son nom c'est ça ou pas
est-ce que pedro a est un je vis aussi là-bas
normalement payés méditerranéens et
par la crise des paillettes s'il supporte avec assurance
de sept saintes décorations de journalisme qui
risque de souffrance plafond allemand
paradoxe tu as un modèle que moi
t'inquiète mais plus d'olympiades
mélaré africain et brutal d'un modèle de ce
processus il cette victoire il est bikini et
Je ne sais pas, efofex aime l'attention
et elle préfère avec ces tabi c'est
conséquence économique et sociale de la
pandemy sound pourquoi l'afrique c'est là
frotter la région de monte vain
surface souches appétit in viro this
comme je sais qu'il a tendance à être vu dit
ça marche même à partir de son fait de modèle dans le
Je vois que c'est une inégalité de grossesse et de
situation existante et édifiante
économiques et sociaux qui sont cellulaires ok
eh bien, salut à tous, je m'attends à ce que la paresse
pandémique doc e e pour renvoi applaudi et
sécher à la télé normale il y a des coeurs coeurs
à la fin d'ici aussi en répétant que
Le continent africain et les gens sont ici et
la part de gagné et le chef civil gagnent
joão bianco jour avec noir et son
Christian
la danse dynamique d'en afrique se lisse
les gens émergents papa s'il est pour moi
par la population d'un jury de plus
Brésilien à
et là